de prendre de haut la palme d'or je vous
en étiez vous êtes prêts c'est pour
maintenant bordeaux
la palme d'or décernée à titane j'ai 38
ans avait déjà remporté ce trophée en 93
x leçon de piano mais elle avait dû le
partager avec shine qualité et adieu ma
concubine julia ducournau
la première est les actrices sacrés seul
pas le mot d'or pour titane
cette histoire perturbant qui a
électrisé la croisette - au pied interné
par vincent hein
il prend pour son fils
ces films de genre sur lequel plane
on veut racheter d'aline paul albert
présentée ici même à cannes dans les
années 90 est actuellement en salle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'équipe ché qui m'arrêtent désolé je
suis française j'adore magnifique
incroyable spies c'est grâce à cette
soirée a été ici est incroyable
maintenant je vais voir les français
quand mes parents me regarde en ce
moment même quand j'étais petit c'est un
rituel chez nous de regarder cérémonie
de clôture a été avec mes parents et à
cette époque j'étais sûr que tous les
films primés ne devait être parfait
puisqu'il avait l'honneur d'être sur
cette scène et ce soir c'est sur cette
scène et je sais que mon film n'est pas
parfait je sais que mon film n'est
parfait mais
je pense qu'aucun film n'est parfait aux
yeux de celui ou celle qui la fait de
toute façon on dit même du mien qu'il
est monstrueux
vous savez maintenant je suis devenu
l'adulte et réalisatrice je me rends
compte que de la perfection c'est pas
que c'est une chimère c'est que c'est
l'impasse
c'est l'impasse et la monstruosité qui
fait peur certains qui traverse mon
travail c'est une arme mais c'est une
force pour faire repousser les murs de
la normativité qui nous enferme et qui
nous sépare ce qui attend il ya tant de
beauté d'émotion et de liberté a trouvé
dans ce qu'on ne peut pas mettre dans
une case
et dans ce qui reste à découvrir de nous
je voulais remercier infiniment le jury
de reconnaître avec ce prix le besoin à
vis de viscéral qu'on a d'un monde plus
inclusif et plus fluide
merci au jury d'appeler pour plus de
diversité dans nos expériences au cinéma
et dans nos vies et merci au jury de
laisser entrer les monstres
voudrais partager ce prix avec toute mon
équipe avec mes attaques terrasson et
agathe qui se sont donnés corps et âme
aux soucis
à mon producteur qui m'a accompagné dans
les pires montagnes russes du monde à
mes distributeurs et vendeurs qui sont
tombés amoureux de mon bébé avant même
qu'ils soient nés et surtout je dois le
partager avec chaque technicien qui
s'est battu contre vents et marées
contrôler presque deux années horribles
qu'on vient de vivre qui a tenu bon
malgré les ajournements pour faire
exister titane et la portée jusqu'ici
je pense aussi à mes parents puisqu'ils
me regarde et je voulais les remercier
de m'avoir soutenue dans tous les choix
que j'ai fait dans ma vie et de m'avoir
aidé à être libre merci à tous du fond
du coeur
[Musique]
vous
mais
voilà je vais demander au jury et à tous
les lauréats et ainsi qu'à leur
permettant de nous rejoindre sur scène
j'ai pas s'ils sont derrière c'est la
fin de ce soixante quatorzième festival
de cannes
merci pierre lescure merci thierry
frémaux merci spike lee de m'avoir fait
faire des aller retour sur la scène
merci tu as un rêve d'avoir été traduire
ce que je disais à spike lee
merci julia ducournau dati courageuse
merci jodie foster parce que j'attends
un condensé son nom on était sur canal+
merci maxime saada
le film de clôture ce soir c'est aurait
eu 117 alerte rouge en afrique noire
venez on va tous avancer pour faire une
photo
[Musique]
l'utp tous milieux
il
mais nous voilà
ouais